alors soyez l'un ou la bienvenue bonjour
tout le monde autour de la planète
ici on est réuni on est trois pour le
moment venu on sera 4 très très bientôt
on a le droit d'arriver encore à
l'émission on à droite avant la fin
d'émission
si vous avez des nouvelles technologies
on peut réinventer les règlements et
donc les patrons n'ont rien à dire nous
c'est la fête comme tous les vendredis
bien sûr 11h11 presque 12 à l'heure de
montréal c'est leur magic des diffusions
de tam-tam canada originaire de bonne
humeur je suis effectivement vous l'êtes
aussi on est bien sur balles
mais oui marie claude savard en pleine
forme en pleine forme en arrivant en
attendant notre invité spécial autres
invités qui se fait attendre
non non on va dévoiler d'affaires quand
même aujourd'hui et le sujet est sérieux
soit on a des sujets amusant la semaine
dernière on parlait quand même la
frontière canadienne des trucs pour
passer sans les papiers au canada et aux
etats unis soutiennent beaucoup de
réactions en fait ce qui gêne à je ne
sais pas moi georges louis pommiers de
réactions j'ai beaucoup de laïcs ces
messages écrits non aussi beaucoup de
monde on emprunter ce passage
oui près de fond ce sera pour écouter
l'émission précédent sur facebook pour
voir de quoi on parle seulement comment
pas aller aux états unis sans vos
papiers sans papiers d'identité ses bons
+ mexicain c'est bon pour les gens comme
cela nous avait déjà trois minutes qu'on
est en ondes au départ parce que c'est
un droit que vous avez exercé les
jusqu'à la fin en voyant des parties à
aller s'asseoir
si ce concept est passé de quoi on va
discuter aujourd'hui oui s'interpose
pour ceux qui lisent pas la cemac et
comme un mot aux chutes d'avant dreux de
tam-tam canada mais enfin pour ceux qui
ne lisent pas voici on vous dis
aujourd'hui on va regarder ce qui s'est
passé charleville
samedi dernier les événements qui ont
suivi pas seulement par avant de succès
parce aux états unis de ce qui s'est
passé chez nous
on commençait à se regarder le nombril
puis on a commencé un petit peu à
s'inquiéter puis à se dire ce qui se
passe sous la barre le dérapage entre le
populisme et le sud les idées
suprémacistes il est très mince
c'est iain glissade guide est ici c'est
avec un risque est vrai qu'on en discute
ensemble qu'on voit comment on est
différent pourquoi ces événements ne
pourrait pas se produire chez nous
pourquoi il pourrait se produire chez
nous comprendre mieux le site société
québécoise et canadienne à travers les
mondes charleville ça vous convient oui
oui j'ai ici criant en grosse ligne
qu'est ce que c'est marqué ici parlement
entre les propos populistes et les
discours suprémacistes et québécois
voilà j'aurais pu résumer toute la
sphère à cette simple phrase pour le
thème aujourd'hui pour tout regarder les
images de charleville la vidéo numéro 1
à valence et jodie on est organisés ici
alors ces images elles ont été tournées
par weiss qui est une organisation que
je connais pas ce que quelqu'un connait
vance peut m'expliquer c'est quoi
exactement
barry smith c'est une organisation des
journalistes indépendants as
indépendance il porterait gars je dirais
nouveau très frais rafraîchissement sur
la réelle actualité donc sept reportages
celui-ci en particulier est vraiment
très bien fait parce qu'ils sont rentrés
dans le l'écart de cette manifestation
des suprémacistes blancs hausse est
signé à charles autres villes ils sont
vraiment discuter avec eux donc on a pu
vraiment comprendre le point de vue des
ces gens-là savoir ce qui les motive
savoir la priorité connaître la priorité
donc c'était très intense et qu est-ce
qu est-ce que quelqu'un ici autour de la
terre peut me dire ce qu'on a découvert
au sujet du québec dans les images
tournées par weiss parfait seulement
quelques cd quoi et on a installé dans
le
le langage de certaines personnes qui
apparaissent sur dans la vidéo il y
aurait un accent québécois sont parlé
d'au moins 12 personnes et je trouve que
effectivement on a découvert par la
suite car on a confirmé certains médias
ont fonctionné parce qu'il y avait deux
je pense néanmoins des temps où il
neigeait beaucoup l'expression au moins
deux postes étaient moins que ça et
avant qu'on fait cette découverte que ce
soit non si je pensais je dis ou
mercredi bien sûr on commence à se poser
des questions mais est ce que ça
pourrait se produire chez nous parce que
des discours populistes y en a eu chez
nous contre les immigrants contre contre
les juifs on a déjà entendu ça contre
les musulmans également alors nous on
regarde son ensemble on est prêt pour
l'autre vidéo et je vous montrais là on
va dans le coeur de la bête d'accord on
descend quand je les sens pas très beau
là parce que j'ai fait beaucoup de
recherches cette semaine et j'ai entendu
bien des choses et je peux vous dire que
j'ai eu une journée mercredi très
difficile au plan personnel par rapport
à ce soir là mais tout à il y avait un
point de départ professionnel regarder
ça là présentement c'est c'est un jeune
en 2009 a pas je pensais que cette à
toronto mais c'est à vancouver s'est
lancée on voit ça et il ya peu j'ai
enlevé le son et on a donc trois jeunes
voyous des skinheads qui s'attaquent un
jeune noir
aucune raison le jeune circulait là il
s'attaque à lui et il va passer il va
être un héros il sera comme ça décrit
par les journaux canadiens parce que
bien sûr il va y laisser quelques dents
mais il va se défendre jusqu'au bout il
va gagner entre heure imed son argument
contre ces [ __ ] qui étaient là pour
le connaissez et il ya eu de la violence
on parle pas souvent de quelques coups
de poing mais on va regarder ça ensemble
on encore vous regardez ça je sais que
je voterai françois y est réalisé avec
ses salles cesser la violence là c'est
ça la violence au canada et moi je mets
+12 regardant ça je ne peux que penser à
mon propre ensemble mais sans fin oui
qu'est ce qu'il ferait s'il s'était
confronté à une situation comme celle là
à ses yeux c'est juste triste de ne pas
savoir de quelle manière et je ne vois
pas quel jeune réagir et une situation
comme ça il ya des gens qui commencent à
arriver sur la scène avec leur véhicule
je pense que personne qui ose descend de
son véhicule pour confronter trois
personnes qui tentaient la brouille les
cartes se brouillent les cartes on voit
que là il ya comme le ton change
c'est en plein ce qui s'approche du
jeûne avant sur une manne à ce que vous
êtes
est ce que tu vas bien et les jeunes
s'enfuyant non il veut pas avoir de
témoins voilà là aujourd'hui les témoins
ce sont les caméras on l'a vu avec une
caméra de la ville en fête qui a fini
par se dénoncer une simple citoyenne
comme ceux d'allaoui week end
alors écoutez ça c'était la vidéo chat
pour vous montrer que cette violence
elle peut avoir en son temps dans le
canada je pense que personne on est tous
nés ou nous ils entrent n'en doutait oui
j'arrive à une question maintenant parce
que je voudrais comprendre l'historique
de ces choses-là et voter c'est une
question qui met à l'épreuve vos
connaissances on aperçoit vraiment
l'émission la question je pars
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est fini c'est la question
etes-vous intelligent en plus
d'arrivants d'accord voici la question
on pouvait vrai ou faux
en 1921 en ontario et dans les quatre
provinces de l'ouest du canada être
membre du ku kux klan canadien quant au
faux vrai qu'edf vendrait mais je devrai
aussi il faut non pas au canada anglais
dans l'ouest canadien mais ok d'accès
d'axa comment abordes quatre ans avant
partout ailleurs au pays
c'est dans la province du québec qu'on a
eu des premiers adhérents kux klan
il y avait une question de
2 ce qui est bizarre parce que souvent
les fougasses candidate ci contre la
religion catholique mais là c'était des
bons catholiques
quand je vais décrire et comme qui se
sont dit voilà une façon de défendre
notre couleur notre couleur ou blangy
demande celle de la majorité à cette
époque
et après ça s'est transportée en ontario
et dans l'ouest canadien et c'est en
saskatchewan où le mouvement était plus
fort on parle de quelques années
seulement
2027 là ça commençait à s'effriter et
que ses voyages en train
non mais j'aime et que cette réalité de
1927 ne se reproduise pas en 2027
ben je peux vous dire que présentement
il semble y avoir moins d'adeptes
dossier de ce gros bloc 1 avait en
saskatchewan
dans cette seule province mais john ils
étaient combien après vous en 1927 rouge
sommet de cette vague de popularité du
coup quoique cela on sait le tour de
table
marie claude est ce qu'on faisait un
truc quoi nous avait enterrés de l'année
j'allais dire mille mots et désirs leurs
danses en sa personne mais là quand même
la décote demandée cette époque là
aujourd'hui il ya moins d'un million oui
c'est vrai qu'elle est passée n'avait
encore moins sa mèche pour maman m'a dit
que je serais capable de concevoir
ah bon alors là il y en avait 40 milles
dans cette province devait compter
d'après moi peut-être cinq cent mille
habitants des transhumants mot est
incroyable la période du mouvement très
fort à ce moment là voilà l'image de ce
qui s'est passé l'époque que je suis ni
un vrai parce que vous êtes prêt à faire
un bout de chemin encore voyage avec
pendant longtemps alors elle et lui on
va on se replaçant à 2027
non non non en 2010 12h02 - et vidéos
numéro 3 nous sommes prêts
en fait nous ne manque qu'une poignée de
signature on manque un peu moins de 26
ans la maman n'organise d'année le
mapouka signature sébastien poirier
fondateur du mouvement traditionaliste
du québec d'y avoir réservé un autre
parti auprès du directeur général des
élections du québec
on ne va pas quand on voit à long terme
donc on croit que c est m
les platines en place un poirier est
d'avis que la culture québécoise est
menacé par le nombre de migrants qui ne
sont pas la couleur de la majorité
contre cette idée massive
l'arrivée massive qui menace la culture
[Musique]
qui ont eu ce plutôt à intégrer
davantage qui rentrent au pays et à
filtrer davantage si une création tout
ce que ce ne sont pas tous de bonne foi
et ils ne veulent pas tous rentrer ici
pour s'intégrer il est plutôt à essuyer
d'un usage et leur contenu
est-ce qu'on peut l'avantager c'est à
nous de les prendre en charge on n'est
pas responsable
elle est belle et rien eu qu'un ancien
skinhead ou insiste pour nous explique
comment ça fonctionne ce moment là
quelqu'un qui qui ce qui est allé de
l'autre côté qui a décidé d'être un
agent du bien après avoir été un
fondateur du mal ou un artisan du mal on
est pressé pour nous voir ex fondateur
du site web de la fédération des
québécois de souche quel beau nom 1
entre guillemets je suis du cynisme et
moi pas à la lettre
alors lui il a changé son fusil d'épaulé
parce qu'il a été arrêté par la police
n'a compris que
en fait une erreur pour la chose qu'on
voit sur la page fan assume québécois de
souche
une nouvelle no job mais sont tout seuls
bs au genre de comparaisons douteuses
que les racistes fondre pour
l'immigration
maxime fils et l'ex fondateur du site
web de la fédération des québécois de
souche c'est texte supprime insiste
collabore maintenant avec le centre
québécois de prévention de la
radicalisation menant à la violence
jamais ils vont parler en mal d'idées
ils vont utiliser en cette barque
boutade de legé car nous allons répondre
à 6,9 contre une religion l'islam mais
on constate si on suit leur fils assez
longtemps qu'ils sont également tous ses
mythes mais ils vont simplement s'en
cacher je n'aime pas non plus des propos
sont ouvertement raciste ils vont
chercher à édulcorer leur discours tous
derrière c'est l'objectif que j'avais
moi même quand j'étais le chef de cette
organisation là et d'une chorale du sco
pour le rendre plus politiquement
correct ce qui est paradoxal parce qu'en
même temps ils dénoncent le
politiquement correct et ils ont presque
tous voter conservateur certains vont
voter pour le bloc
mais sur la scène québécoise la cac et
relativement populaire où son bonheur
que le gaucher de se positionner un peu
comme un peu comme un tram soft il y
avait joué un peu là-dessus lopy il
faudrait rouvrir la question
d'immigration n'est pas encore de groupe
politique d'hygiène très visible s'ils
tiennent un discours d'extrême droite
mais il ya des tentatives comme deux
front national en ce moment la
fédération des québécois de souche
atalante québec qui est un groupe de
skinheads de la région québec très très
actifs sont très visibles pour lui de
propagande ces vidéos l'eau circule
[Musique]
oui
aujourd'hui ces groupes ceux qui ne
disent pas là on est des espaces à il
attire les jeunes en alsace chez tu
mérite d'avoir un bon emploi et au soir
du temps n'a pas un bon rapport à ce
qu'il tombe on voit les tons emploi ceux
qui sont arrivés là qu'ont donc en
dessous des interviews des imids c'est
souvent presque toujours les immigrés
qui sont visés ça rejoint et si
bizarrement je trouve le thème de
comment s'appelle ce monsieur la maison
blanche j'allais utiliser pleinement
qu'ils viennent en tête mais aucun
d'entre eux qui étaient du canadien dont
clinique contre l'immigration certaines
formes d'immigration
ce n'était pas originaire de l'allemagne
où sa famille noms étranges comme on
oublie vite que nos sinistres que je ne
savais pas où il louait la famille trump
est originaire d'allemagne est arrivé il
ya pas très longtemps fait pas au siècle
dernier donc 1900 mais la fin des années
1800 et le grand père john strand s'est
installée ou du conte et il a fait
fortune fortune avec c'était la ruée
vers l'or alors il avait un hôtel et ben
il se passer beaucoup de choses en cause
l otan de la prostitution que pleins
pleins d'autres choses mais finalement
il s'est enrichi et il est partout aux
états unis alors voilà je voudrais
rappeler à monsieur de forme qu'il a
quand même des origines autre que nord
américains
il ya beaucoup de gens qui veulent
rappeler certaines choses à monsieur 32
mois mais là ce monstre qui l'écoutent
ouvert ça si d'autres ne le savaient pas
voilà il est lui même
cet aspect ne quitterait catastrophiste
ans donc c'est quelque chose qui hérite
d'une crise il faut agir maintenant une
victimisation assez forte s'il de la
majorité donc on est victime des autres
on est victime du gouvernement
évidemment dans tout bon discours
populiste il ya une vérification de 2
litres se dire que l'élite politique et
économique peu importe est toujours un
complot de l'élite pourrait servir la
population que ce soit par des réformes
internes au temps des réformes
économiques ou encore par une
immigration massive qui vont faire
descendre des conditions de vie des
peuples dont ils sont des choses qu'on
voit évidemment on cherche encore la
marginalise x + 6 saisons ceux qui sont
jugés différents en use it dans ce site
c'est assez cet incident qui va
évidemment on sent ici de cette idée de
désir de passer à l'action en est
d'abord des mesures plus coercitives le
qui sont évidemment nécessaires pour que
la catastrophe est imminente donc tous
ces éléments ne se retrouvent dans ce
disque au lieu que ce soit un bond de 12
missiles en europe et ces gens le sont
sortis de l'ombre ils ont ils prennent
la place sur les dans l'espace public
pour s'exprimer pour dire haut et fort
mais il faut lever aussi ils ont promis
leur discours donc voyons donc et par
l'idée héritée de nos deux groupes de
choses comme ça mais on voyait qu'on
défend notre propre groupe qu'on défend
l'amour de notre propre groupe donc ou
encore aurait évité de nous on va parler
de droit et qui plutôt que de contrôler
les choses en face aux banquiers oui
effectivement ils sont beaucoup plus
présents oui effectivement il s'exprime
beaucoup plus ils font des actions
d'éclat ce qu'on a vu effectivement
cette semaine sur youtube mais aussi
promouvoir apparemment en fin de semaine
prochaine donc au québec de façon à
pouvoir se présenter comme d un crédit d
interlocuteur politique valable
là les funérailles de la jeune femme et
celles aux yeux verts 52 ans et oui et
c'est le coût des secours moi qui me
disait regardez autour de vous si vous
voulez changer quelque chose regardez
autour de vous quelque chose que vous
pourriez changer tous individuellement
pour ce printemps des spencer d'aller
dans les grands les grands combats
il faut saisir des petites choses et du
moment et cd corrigibles mon fils
dernièrement que sur internet sur
facebook et autres médias sociaux ils
étaient moins souvent des messages pro
tamisage et raciste souvent de l'âme la
l'incompréhension les jugements rapides
ou des blagues qui se sent qu'ils ne
sont pas les blagues la réalité mais qui
veulent passer que par des blagues
donc je lui ai réfléchi parce qu'ils me
disent heureux de recevoir ça comme
information mais je dis mais qu'est ce
que toi c'est d'accord n'ont donc est ce
que tu peux faire quelque chose
il m'a dit maintenant mais moi je m'en
veux pas me mettre effectivement il va
pas se mettre à un conflit avec
quelqu'un sur l'internet
en même temps est-ce qu'il faut toujours
dire ce qu'il faut toujours un très
dense et distinct ces discussions qui
peuvent devenir très public nous les
ressources nous aurions donc il ya
toutes ces questions dans l'accord dans
la vie quotidienne en eau jour au jour
le jour à un présence des gens oui on
peut peut-être à agir mais sur
l'internet est ce qu'on doit le savoir
je me suis posé la question vous avec
l'autre vous poser des questions en ce
moment mais je trouve que justement
injuste le centre un peu du problème ce
qui ya passé de discussions sur le sujet
depuis donne sans rester de tout un
chacun évidemment mais ses rangs dit
seulement névralgiques comme sujet qu'on
nous même pu poser une question même si
on la pose avec des gants blancs
non plus interrogé sur mes mais en fait
qui sont ces personnes guéries vol avec
leurs valises à la se situe elle suppose
la question des jackets comédie culte
est tellement rapidement
c'est vrai que le sens pour la critique
que tous les taux fixes moi je trouve
que c'est un problème que c'est vraiment
ce qui fait que justement l'intolérance
de vie de plus en plus aiguë c'est parce
que j ai pas d espace où on peut je sais
ce qu'on peut juste se parler ce qu'on
peut juste repérage et ouais parce que
tu es et le fait d'être intolérant par
rapport aux jeunes qui tombent dans le
vide de l'être suprême c'est tout si
marc de l'injustice à leur égard je
pesais faut entendre tout cela mais bon
il ya une façon de faire font intervenir
mais il faut pas les laisser tomber
quelque part ces jeunes là un jour ils
pourraient devenir des steve fiset et et
revoir leur façon de faire pas justement
ce ne sont pas n'importe qui qui peut
avoir une inquiétude par rapport à la
situation actuelle en ce moment ça fait
une personne d'une autre génération une
personne et vous ne pouvez pas dans le
tout en faveur des inquiétudes légitimes
viendront ce même pas contrôler si tu
ressens quelque chose à l'intérieur de
toi qui inquiète ce sera ton contrôle
dans ce qu'il faudrait 40 a cherché un
format sans fin que tout de suite la
forme et du fond des âges personnage
raciste
parfois je fais associés notamment ça
les gens font l effort sur internet de
celui-ci de toute personne qui aurait
peut-être des biens avec un groupe alors
je trouve que se crée un climat
complètement paranoïaque tendu parce que
dans le sens effectivement comme un huis
clos lundi on a le droit de se poser des
questions la commission de l'immigration
et du statut de réfugié dit la situation
telle qu'elle est actuellement avec le
demandeur d'asile est insoutenable
il ya trop de monde qui arrive on n'a
pas les ressources il faut qu on se
débrouille des cinq sens un peu
improviser avec cette situation et ça
c'est une réalité y vivent des choses et
il ya des questions de santé publique
qui sont en jeu il y a plusieurs choses
on a le droit de se poser ces
questions-là
en même temps on n'a pas le droit de
juger sans s'informer
donc l'idée ce que les gens prennent le
temps de s'informer et de poser des
questions mais s'il sent fort de poser
des questions pour date départ justement
de ces paraissent très débridée
tolérance est raciste il dit alors ne se
fait pas j'aime réussi faire intervenir
un dialogue dont journalistique parce
qu'on est des gens de personnalités
publiques et peut-être que notre
discours est encore trop bien léché il
est possible qu'il soit prendre non mais
je vous il a obtenu lorsque c'est
possible
pauvre et la porte à la possibilité à
consommer bien branché c'est ce qu'on
disait les partisans de 30 e ils savent
de quoi christine pas vraiment et les
médecins n ont aucune idée
alors ouvrons la porte à ces gens qui
sont présentement de l'autre côté de la
caméra qui sont des internautes comme
nous l'aimons professionnels évidemment
mais qui en leur moisir question tomtom
canada cette semaine vous nous rappeler
la question marie-claude donc la montée
violente des suprémacistes comme celle
observée aux états unis est elle un
problème qui pourrait à vos yeux aussi
prendre racine au canada où serions nous
en bonne partie immunisés au monde vous
répondu à sort un peu notre façon
aujourd'hui
alors voici d'abord la réponse de
raymond caille un sou aya au québec
je demande à quelqu'un qu'il souffle
long anne marivin ces trois longs
paragraphes ça va durer une unité
qu'elle gardons dans ce encore mais il a
beaucoup à dire
en écoute alors monsieur ray moyens''
nous dit il n'y a pas de problème de
suprématie ce mot canada
par contre il existe certainement une
intolérance envers des idées
conservatrices et traditionnelle par
exemple malgré mon origine immigrée d'un
pays du moyen-orient
je suis souvent insulter publiquement dû
à mon orientation sexuelle et à la
couleur de ma peau et ce malgré le fait
que je n'ai aucun contrôle sur la
composition de mon adn
juste parce que j'exprime un certain
patriotisme et des idées conservatrices
et chrétienne sur les réseaux sociaux
comme facebook et youtube
et il ajoute il ajoute à la suite des
événements de charlottesville je suis
assimilé depuis quelques jours aux
néonazis car j'ai osé avancer l'idée que
peut-être à wil dit que peut-être pas
tous les manifestants étaient adeptes
des thèses hitlériennes ou membres du
kkk et blasphèmes qu'il existe des
groupuscules soi-disant d'extrême gauche
qui sont extrêmement violent et qui ont
activement cherché la bagarre mais ce
n'est pas fini
alors il ajoutant mon opinion ce qui est
consternant et cet acharnement à faire
disparaître tout discours qui ne va pas
dans le sens de la rectitude politique
du jour des autorités qui oeuvrent à
démonter des monuments et contrôler le
langage des gens c'est ça qui va causer
de la frustration chez les gens qui se
sentent visés
empêcher les gens de s'exprimer changer
l'histoire
tout là va exacerber les tensions qui
existent c'est ce qui va mousser le
racisme et peut-être même le
suprématisme et il conclut nous ne
sommes pas encore rendus là mais nos
gouvernements doivent prendre acte pour
éviter cette éventualité qu'il vient de
bure ce que vous exprimiez surtout de
votre côté marie chloé mais toujours en
gardant est évidemment que on ne juge
pas quelqu'un sur la couleur de sa peau
d un peuple ne souffrira jamais dans
l'excès de compassion humain alors il
faut celui je pense qu'il faut quand
même ce pour bien s'assurer que ce qui
motive nos questionnements aussi c'est
fort justement des préjugés qu'on en
rêve mais l'important c'est de se poser
des questions je donne aux plus de mardi
qu'on passe notre vidéo parce qu on a
une réaction qui vient des états unis
comme une bonne distance de charleville
charleville c'est à cent kilomètres sans
mobile en nombre en langage américain
700 miles donc 160 km
washington à moyenne taille julie de
monsieur 30 et steve stevens qui dans la
ville de new york et new york c'est une
ville qui est à peu près à 180 km de
washington donc environ rendu d'une
telle mission
voici ce que steam ou steven existe
cette semaine me demander à laval au
moteur il est certain qu'elle essaie
vainement d'échalotes ville d'où j'avais
près vous sont réveillés au canada vous
souciez vous savez un problème avec les
discours populistes je me souviens des
cas le parti québécois était au pouvoir
je crois en 2014 et sans raciste projet
des chats de chartes de droits qui
voulaient y posséder 60 blanche de
s'habiller à peu près tout le monde
chaque fois que des politiciens se
montre intransigeant et maîtrise en cela
finit toujours par faire mal
pas seulement sur le moment mais pendant
des années je pense que le québec du
parti québécois était aussi raciste que
notre bouffe ans de présidence ivan de
la ville de new york en c'est un point
de vue publié l'extérieur oui absolument
que vous les perceptions des gens de
l'extérieur on voit des choses que
probablement sur x lion voyons pas
toujours répondre mais des fois le
racisme l'intolérance n'est toujours de
la même chose à la racine et est simple
on a peur de l'étranger peur et
l'ignorance et la peur ça c'est vraiment
oui c'est l'ignorance et la peur de
l'étranger
c'est différent de nous ça fait peur
pimkie et je crois que ça vient des ça
mais ça mes amis aussi pour certaines
personnes en tout cas des deux notions
de supériorité je crois ben je vais vous
raconter une histoire
quand je suis arrivé au canada
auparavant peut-être non aux envies des
banquiers en 1917
je sais pas moi je suis immigrantes
aussi au canada pendant je suis j'ai la
couleur de peau de
la grande majorité des canadiens et je
suis arrivé ici à 12 ans dans une école
et j'ai été battu pourquoi sauf que
j'étais une étrangère j'arrivais
d'ailleurs je faisais peur vous alles
été battus lorsque vous aviez 12 enfants
oui j'étais battu elle ne le mangent été
battu à l'école parce que j'étais une
étrangère
je suppose qu'ils leur supérieur aux 2 1
non non non
résumé c'était dans cette région là où
le village va nécessairement ne pas nous
offre une occasion de vous vos 2 mais
c'est un petit village dans sa vie c'est
pas la même chose qu'à montréal où seuls
à montréal à l'époque qui avait déjà
plus d'immigrants on en voyait plus mais
nous dans cette école à y avait personne
d'une autre couleur que la couleur
blanche et j'arrivais avec un accent
différent j'étais une minorité audible
et on me l'a bien fait comprendre une
personne qui vous ressemblent beaucoup
ce genre cultivé l'image le son sur le
facebook c'est madame françoise
depardieu or ma nouvelle équipe
bon je pense que oui je sais que ça
faisait plaisir à mme marie qu'on lui
donne le pcq même sociale donne ceux de
la france je me rappelle plus exactement
à quel village ou qu'elle me canoy moins
que nous a pas écrit et puis je me mets
vous madame de tardieu alignons non dans
trois là je me rate ému mais ne répond à
la question cette semaine par rapport au
fait est ce que nous risquons ici au
québec de tomber du populisme
le vin au verre le suprématisme je n'ai
pas vraiment avec des mots barbares est
notre cas c'est l'idée générale alors on
écoute la réponse
alors d'abord bonjour les amis canadiens
et elles disent que vous veniez de dire
décidément il ya longtemps que je ne
vous avais pas d'écrit moi je pense que
des populistes comme marine le pen ou
donald l'américain nous font tous
glisser vers un monde où l'
intransigeance devient la norme au
québec vous me semblez plus tolérants
mais je crois que ce n'est qu'une
question de temps
les immigrants nous submerge et nous
ébranler nous n'avons pas toujours la
patience de nos bonnes intentions de
départ qui est d'ouvrir nos bras à ceux
qui sont dans le besoin
alors l'option fermé mission vous êtes
encore on va laisser les gens pensent
que leur réflexion sans apporter de
points de conclusion pouvoir penser à
tout ça sur la page de facebook
c'est aux gens qui sont là de remplir
les cases c'est plus qu'une carte sont
potes on vous met pas dans des cases
vous pouvez écrire autant que vous
voulez et ken l'élite sur facebook sur
la longueur de maintenant je pense que
vous devriez tester la faire pour nous
voir jusqu'à quel point d'accord pour
avoir un texte non l'on en est plein on
ne dira pas au lit tous alors elle
marivaux merci beaucoup d'être venu
cette semaine
et dire que marion la section section
ceux de ces deux cd kiptoo espace
autochtones dommage la paloma martinez
de la section latino américaine qui
travaille cette semaine à la section
française et la vie m'est très cher vous
êtes là la semaine prochaine on retrouve
à l'émission est crétin c'est le rêve
c'est vrai je venais d'arriver en avance
ah ouais parce que des fois ça rajoute
pas travailler ce vendredi pour faire
démissionner
je ne serai pas là mais madame depardieu
quand même écrire avec claude merci
d'avoir assumé comme ça le manteau de la
technique aujourd'hui semaine
[Musique]